[Applause]
Prince Harry and Megan Markel are making
moves this isn't a couple I'd like to
sit still and do not think the couple
spent Wednesday volunteering with
homeboys and homegirls of homeboy
industries in LA check out this photo of
the Sussex is preparing food for the
hashtag feed Hope program which provides
meals to the food insecure seniors and
youth across the city in the wake of the
COBIT 19 pandemic and here's a close-up
of making hard at work in the cafe the
power of food is more than just the meal
itself it is the story behind it the
Duchess has a long-standing history with
the organization that works to improve
the lives of formerly incarcerated and
previously gang involved Angelenos you
are going to have empathy for those who
don't see the world through the same
lens that you do because with as diverse
and vibrant and open-minded as I know
the teachings and immaculate heart are I
know you know that black lives matter
remember the impassioned speech Megan
recently gave to graduating seniors at
her alma mater
well homeboy Industries founder father
Greg Boyle worked closely with the high
school and Megan and her mom Doria
Ragland actually participated in a
cooking workshop he led almost twenty
years ago the Duchess still remembers
the tamale recipe they learned recently
Megan and Harry have been speaking with
father Boyle about the racial justice
movement they're speaking to community
leaders and from a number of different
organizations and charities and told
this is really where they want to focus
their energy and make a difference of
the Sussex is visit father Boyle says
they were just Harry and Megan to those
they were serving adding quote they
rolled up their sleeves and deeply
engaged with their workers in the bakery
and cafe it was immediate kinship and
hurt me in its mutuality but
volunteering isn't the only thing this
couple has been up to we're a fantastic
team we know real ET has also learned
that Megan and Harry have signed with
the Harry Walker agency for speaking
engagements according to our source the
firm also represents the
and it will offer this Sussex is a
source of income as they branch out on
their own
I heard that helps you understand what
did it come to that I would step my
family back from all I have ever known
just take us to take a step forward into
what I hope can be a more peaceful life
but the source close to the couple says
there is one topic that's off-limits
the royal family adding that the concern
is any additional talk of their royal
lives could bring further discomfort
within the royal family and we already
know things have been tense we're still
together for the rest of our lives this
is true togetherness / the source Megan
and Harry are quote firmly committed to
social issues the world is facing now
including racial injustice gender
equality and mental health this is
something that Megan particularly is
very passionate about and she feels that
having spoken out about race about
racial equality she sees herself as a
role model
she believes that there is an
expectation on her to address what's
going on and to support and that is what
they're doing the source adds that the
couple is expected to participate in
keynote speeches trade events and
community forums to quote further their
philanthropic goals the only wrong thing
to say is to say nothing
[Music]
you